hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday April 18th 2016 was going on - oh
I I don't even like I don't know where
to start on this [ __ ] one how do you
begin this one and still be sensitive
sensitive there's so many sensitive
stories out there and when there is when
there's feelings there in full this
[ __ ] leg got a zoo in Palm Beach
Florida
rest his soul got attacked and killed
got mauled by a [ __ ] tiger sometimes
referred to as the tiger Whisperer yadda
yadda yadda yadda yadda yadda yadda and
all that [ __ ] [ __ ] these I don't know
what it is about people who fall in love
with wild animals but there's nothing
you can do to cure it it's [ __ ] it
doesn't give a [ __ ] about you it's not a
dog you know falling in love with a wild
animal it's like fall in love with a
stripper yeah it's just not going to end
well not gonna end well [ __ ]
unbelievable that is another story this
[ __ ] Scout leader takes a bunch of
Boy Scouts takes a bunch of children
into the [ __ ] woods he goes into a
cave and there's a [ __ ] bear in there
so the whole story is always an amazing
that the Boy Scouts kept their [ __ ]
cool the guy knew that Scout leader knew
that he pulled his shirt up over his
face and then curled up into the fetal
position which I guess is the
international bear signal like hey man I
don't want any part of this man and then
the bear lost interest and walked away
but at no point during all of this does
anybody say hey the [ __ ] you bringing
a bunch of kids around with his bears
just walking around
it's bad enough if you take your kids to
the [ __ ] zoo the amount of times
these goddamn things get loose or at the
very least some fatties going to walk up
to some polar bear cage go over the
[ __ ] thing and stand there you know
and then get [ __ ] snatched by this
thing and what is she saying yeah yeah
what for you should [ __ ] blow your
brains out you dope right so I'm not
saying the lady who died in Florida was
a dope I'm just saying that I don't know
you insert yourself into this situation
and there's no good way to insert
yourself into a mauling to death by a
tiger do you know what that means
there was also they always just say
mauled you know like it came up like
like some prison [ __ ] just stuck you
with the shank it didn't it did [ __ ]
crushed your neck and then it started
feeding on your innards that's [ __ ]
brutal hang on a second Nia okay what
are you doing you coming in alright did
you lock me in okay sorry
she just got she's freaking me out
they're like I got these new locks no
door thought she was locking the door
still early here and I just woke her up
so she's going to be a little grumpy me
if you want to come in on a podcast let
me know
oh that's valid spoke volumes you know
I'll tell you right now getting married
is kind of like a falling in love with a
wild animal you know as much as you love
them don't get too close to this [ __ ]
enclosure yeah let me get back that why
the [ __ ] would you take a bunch of kids
out like no at no point does anybody
address that this guy took a bunch of
[ __ ] children out to where there's
bears and then they watched him get
[ __ ] mauled for half a second before
he took his eyes on a key and yanked it
over his head that's what you're
supposed to do how they been on the
earth this long and not known that
that's what you do when you run to the
bear is it because I'm not in Scouting
or is it because most people are smart
enough to not be around bear
to not reenact the [ __ ] scene from
the Leonardo DiCaprio movie was it
called a rank on there I don't know what
the [ __ ] it is the revelant the
irrelevant whatever the [ __ ] it was
called I hate when they take some big
word that already exists and just makes
you feeling like it's like did they make
that word up and it's like no that word
has existed the revenant right that word
has existed your entire life just you
and everybody you know is too dumb to
walk around and use it on a daily basis
and yeah that's it's a sad feeling just
sad [ __ ] feeling I forget what I was
look how yeah what to do if a bear
attacks you I can tell you right now
this is going to be 99.9% white people
look in the [ __ ] up that's where the
dopes that go out there
I hate to do Jeff GM material but it's
[ __ ] true
jesus [ __ ] christ 2016 and you get
mauled by a grizzly bear there's no
excuse for that and you know you know
hallmark doesn't make a card for it
there you go you can go through all of
that whole sympathy section sorry for
your loss sorry you got this disease
sorry I was a douche yesterday there's
no wow [ __ ] sorry you got mauled by a
bear they don't because it happened so
so little
Sookie you talk there's no reason for it
they should really make one of those you
know and make it even better it should
like rhyme I hate to look I hate to
stare but your face got mauled by a bear
I'm really [ __ ] sorry then I was
talking about a trolley go [ __ ] yourself
I hope you feel better
[Music]
attention all zoo keepers out there
those are not your friends and they
don't want to be there and I think a lot
of them realized the situation then I
just sitting there [ __ ] waiting for
you to give another [ __ ] pile of cube
steaks they're sitting there even if
they were born in captivity I
guaran-fucking-tee you that they are
sitting there with this strange feeling
that there has to be more than this look
at me to look at me if you're a [ __ ]
tiger even you're a tiger born
to captivity right you're rolling around
with somebody dressed in a safari outfit
okay and your bond with that person like
it's your [ __ ] mother right it's some
[ __ ] point at some point you know
just you ego alone with all those people
showing up just to look at you taking
your picture there's no weed there's no
way to keep your feet on the ground you
know and not be like dude I why am I in
a cage right now when everybody's coming
up you know all I do is lay around
everyday these people can't get enough
looking at me I mean I mean I'm the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you know you just start your ego just
goes [ __ ] crazy Lang then you start
looking like you know I know you start
tested they come in a little bit you
give them a little growl you see it in
their face they got some broom handle AG
back right you just go to you know first
time with your paws test the strength of
that funky little broom handle like if I
could snap that thing this guy's [ __ ]
show this guy's a [ __ ] what they're
doing Tiger push-ups room you know and
then one day you just like you know what
much as I'm enjoying this [ __ ] raw
meat I have it every day and I need to
switch up the diet you know but I'm all
you and I usually bail to some dental
floss I know I know what you're thinking
right now you probably think it bill
this is really [ __ ] insensitive well
you know what this is how I deal with
sad [ __ ] I joke around about it because
I don't feel like thinking about
everybody that love that woman that now
can never see her again so I mean what
am I supposed to do and then also I like
to feel that it being responsible by
giving you some tips on how not to uh
yeah you know well you know get get
mauled to death by a bear I just don't
understand that like what's so [ __ ]
funny about these goddamn Scouts it's
like why don't you just go in the woods
you want to go into the goddamn
wilderness you know [ __ ] brings a bunch
of kids out there I'll tell you brings a
bunch of kids out there kind of guy that
goes out just walks into a [ __ ] cave
gets mauled by a [ __ ] bear who the
[ __ ] walks into a cave in the middle of
the forest
what kind of it I mean I'm not in
Scouting
I never was I can't start a fire without
a match but I can tell you right now my
general instincts says that says that
you know there's no apartment buildings
out in the [ __ ] forest okay so a cage
is like that's like a town house in
Brooklyn you know that's these people if
they're [ __ ] digging holes in the
goddamn ground curling up to hibernate
net is a [ __ ] cave all right so you
think everybody who lives out there
that's like [ __ ] that's like Beverly
Hills level property so who's going to
get it the strongest chick is craziest
[ __ ] out there and that's a bear
you know you're not going to walk in
there and it's going to be a little fox
in there like it isn't it's going to be
so [ __ ] it's going to be the king of
the forest which is a bear as far as I
know although I did see a mountain lion
give it a couple of [ __ ] you know
Pernell Whitaker so you know the most
fast that guy was they would [ __ ] it
right on top of his head in a bear just
sat there and taken you know he had like
the head movement of light of late Mike
Tyson rather than early and he just took
a few and then he just sort of started
running away was a sad day you know and
it was just mad if you ran into a badger
or a [ __ ] Wolverine those lunatics
Badgers and Wolverines they're like the
Irish and the scottish of the [ __ ]
forest you know what I mean those things
don't even quit even even if they're
losing him they just got that I don't
give a [ __ ] you know blood all over the
face then I stop and they're going to
keep coming just like the Irish and the
Scottish [ __ ] lunatics you don't want
any part any part of that well you know
I don't know you know I never even
looked at sake a bear encounters in
backcountry if you encounter a bear on
the trail or in your campsite yeah
because you're cooking food basically
the dinner bell of anything within
[ __ ] oh my God look at the size of
this [ __ ] bear well there's a lady
[ __ ] walking and there's a bear in
the background guess what color she is
alright be safe and bear habitat now god
the first sentence the level I mean is
damaged aya the level of dopes that have
to be come to this website listen this
is the first sentence it's normal it's
normal ticket normal it's normal to be
frightened when you encounter a bear
that's how this this is the jump off
point the reality is that most
encounters with bears rarely rarely lead
to aggressive behavior and attacks are
even rarer here they go sucking into the
forest is a great line they're actually
more afraid of you than you are of them
yeah and what do they do when they get
when they're afraid they either take off
running or they [ __ ] maul you to
death and go eh you know here's a bonus
the threat is gone and now I have a
midday snack remember most bears prefer
to avoid contact with humans that's
hilarious feel like the champion that
doesn't want to fight you know just
trying to hold onto the belt backpedal
in the entire time until you corner the
[ __ ] thing and any bear you do see is
probably just as frightened as you are
there it is
every [ __ ] you know what it is that
Bears don't have access to a mirror
they're living in their head you know
they're out there by themselves you know
talking themselves accountant and you
know not to find a cave or some [ __ ] man
right no so they finally find it nobody
else has been here [ __ ] chill out put
an l-shaped couch over here get a
flat-screen and all of a sudden this
[ __ ] guy comes walking in and it's
goddamn shorts you know what he's
thinking he's thinking to catch a
predator he's probably seen that show -
here comes this [ __ ] pedophile the
bear thinks he's going to get [ __ ] in
the ass and next thing you know he's on
top of this guy alright and the [ __ ]
dude start yanking his shirt over his
head and then the Bears like what the
[ __ ] skies of bottom you know I thought
this guy was trying to rape me now all
of a sudden he's acting like will making
love here and he's being all submissive
this is [ __ ] weirding me out what if
he tells his friends the Bears all
homophobic and then he kills him and why
you know what is a
bunch of little kids watching it all
right that's what camping is and I I
think you know what I have to havin work
that out right there I think
scouting should be illegal you know I
mean we want to get doing first of all
you know dressing those little boys up
like little french maids you know they
will scarfs running around I mean it's
just you wonder why you got all those
sexual predators sex predators sexual
predators I don't sexual chocolate
anyways remain as composed as possible
and follow these simple guidelines
whenever you're in bear country
soon you will you too will have more
composure when citing a bear because you
know what to do at scream bloody murder
and run in the other direction actually
it's exactly the exact opposite of what
you want to do you want to remain calm
and take a step towards the bear that
shows a level of confidence [ __ ]
belts all right first one avoid avoid
avoid yeah like by staying in
civilization the best way to prevent an
unpleasant and unpleasant bear encounter
is to avoid them altogether bears
usually avoid people and most people
don't even know when they've come close
to a bear exactly to ensure a surprise
or on to ensure a surprise or unpleasant
encounter with the bear doesn't occur
avoid moving through bear habitat
silently and alone traveling groups the
larger the better and make lots of noise
by talking or singing and put the iPod
away and pay attention to your
surroundings Jesus Christ I don't know
about that what if the Bears having a
slow [ __ ] couple of days and it's
hungry and you start you know ah we do
zippity-doo-dah zip-a-dee-ay you know
and the bear starts ticking me like you
know what I think it's worth the risk
even though I'm scared I think I could
take that [ __ ] hundred forty pound
dope alright when it happens see how
they wrote that instead of when you're
getting mauled by the bear and you feel
its breath and it's [ __ ] incisors
ripping it your neck when it happens
that's another way of saying that
remain calm and ready your bear spray or
other deterrent what is it your underarm
here stay together if you're in a group
you will appear larger and more
intimidating if you stick together try
to figure out whether the bear is a
grizzly or a black bear hey let's take
running at at 40 miles an hour if you at
all it's over right [ __ ] over try to
figure out whether the bear is a grizzly
or a black bear as you will see below
grizzly bears and black bears tend to
behave differently in a given situation
so it helps to know which species you're
dealing with it's running after you give
me a [ __ ] break I just click here to
see the difference bears at a distance
doing the [ __ ] bear look at these
[ __ ] things dude the fact that one of
these things could pick up Lawrence
Taylor at the height of his [ __ ]
career and throw him through the
uprights you get bear smart society
these [ __ ] people like I don't get it
I mean that has to be why can't you just
go out in your backyard just set up a
tent I mean you you are still outside as
long as you don't go inside you are
camping it's not the same thing man I
got to get out there with his bears I
know what to do right if it's a black
bear black bear they usually lead with
the left you know what I mean the
tradition of for the Grizzlies of South
paws so it's going to be a little bit
weird they definitely have a reach
advantage considering when they stand up
there about eight feet tall so what you
want to do is you want to stay outside
his wheelhouse okay and you want you
want to circle away from his power
perhaps you want to circle to your left
staying away you should the Grizzlies
want to load up that left they go for
the Big Shot they try to steal around
sorry my beating this to death here
objects there's no [ __ ] reason
there's no reason to get killed by a
tiger in the United States of America
they don't live here
they're only one place they're at the
[ __ ] zoo and you know they're in
cages so at some point
you went into the [ __ ] thing did you
just give you add up oh my god what is
the [ __ ] thought when you get yanked
in the second you get out no it's got to
be it
no make it quick I mean this [ __ ] that
would go through your head I'm sorry
this is getting [ __ ] morbid twenty
ways my condolences to the friends and
family to the lady down there in Florida
and my condolences to the the guy with
the Members Only jacket that he yanked
up over his [ __ ] head you know good
on you sir I hope I you I wish you more
luck as you bring children into the
[ __ ] woods [ __ ] idiot what is it
about putting on a [ __ ] uniform that
all of a sudden you think you know
something I just don't get it I um you
know I have all my badges on my shirt
I've been trained Thanks why he's a
jolly good fella they should be seemly
interesting that you know we're never
going to see you again music right
before you go in the woods just to [ __ ]
and remind you of what you're walking
into
anyways so hey the official finally the
official loud I'm allowed to finally say
afters her family has been picked up for
a second season I actually got the news
back in January but for whatever reason
the way Netflix promote stuff which I
would never question considering their
dominating the universe they wanted to
wait until last Friday so it is now
official we are working right now that's
the stuff I've been alluding to that
I've been working on and I was going to
say uh actually this weekend I was
writing an episode so I missed all the
[ __ ] hockey
I saw the series that I'm watching in
st. Louis first the Blackhawks and when
I saw Game two I threw in the [ __ ]
towel I was like that did he gave a game
to the Blackhawks she cannot give a game
to the Hawks you know you had your foot
on their [ __ ] neck he had the goal
the goal was [ __ ] called back or
whatever I can't remember what happened
the goal got caught
back right or Tarasenko his goal got
called back and then it's just like that
coach should have gone down the bench no
let down no let down right what do they
do they go out there that pissed
Tarasenko takes a stupid [ __ ] penalty
the Blackhawks score the goal they steal
the [ __ ] game and I was just like and
I was texting my buddy I was like that
right there is why the Blackhawks win
every [ __ ] year in st. Louis loses
every [ __ ] year whatever the
Blackhawks have that ability to remain
calm when they're down st. Louis for my
whole [ __ ] life has never had that
right right after I said all of that
[ __ ] what are they doing game three I
didn't see the game I just looked at the
highlights
you know they [ __ ] took three quick
penalties in the first period
Chicago scored on the first on the first
one if I was watching that game I'd be
like here we go here we go Chicago is
going to win like the next for the next
four to five and I've been given
beginning state Louis Beal right there
Fred st. Louis came back tied it up 1 1
Chicago scores a goal in the second
period 2 to 1
they're going into the third period in
Chicago this has always said you know
it's over for the Blues it's always been
that way since I don't know how long
it's been going on forever not like the
Blackhawks will give my whole life for
me [ __ ] they went to a nice drought too
but like the new Black Hawks like this
series is over and [ __ ] st. Louis
came back tied it up to 2 and then went
ahead 3-2 with like 6 minutes left and
so a big congratulations to the st.
Louis Blues that huge [ __ ] victory
and I can't wait to see the next game
because I know the Blackhawks cannot be
in it then I just got to go out like
that I you know they're going to tie it
up they're going to go into st. Louis's
might go uh might go 7 I'm open to 7 you
know I don't give a [ __ ] but I'm pulling
for st. Louis I think they're my team
over Dallas just because you know Dallas
was the North Stars right they've only
been Dallas Stars for like what like 20
years and you know I mean those people
down there deputy a bunch of cowboys
whose kid too you know they getting
plastic surgery
you know they got their oil weld and
wife's wearing too much makeup I mean a
different Dallas the big
it's a football town - football state I
love the [ __ ] stars I love the people
on the Stars but like I also like their
[ __ ] college they got Celtic colors I
like that I still like the Stars but you
know I think I think it's time for the
Blues we've been around since 67 they
never won [ __ ] - lets the team I'm
pulling for Chico how come you not ruin
because we didn't make the players but
who would have thought the Blackhawks
head down two games to one to the blues
and the Kings down Oh - to the San Jose
Shaq and actually a buddy of mine who
likes on efforts for family before this
all started he goes I don't give a [ __ ]
he goes the Stanley Cup goes through
Chicago LA and that's what everybody was
saying now granted we're only a couple
of games in here and granted the Kings
are playing the Sharks and and you know
the Sharks are like the San Diego
Chargers if they wore skates you know
every year coming out having this
wonderful [ __ ] regular season and
then they go in the playoffs and they
just [ __ ] the bed so we'll speak they're
up two games to none mom I think Game
four
if you haven't been watching is Tuesday
night Blackhawks first to blue so I
would definitely be checking that out
and I think that's it that's all I had
on hockey right my Celtics I watched
some lose Game one but I'm just like
they're in the [ __ ] playoffs and now
they're a young team they should have
won the game they should have been able
to close it out but they didn't but they
hung in there they got high just a
little young they just got to learn how
to [ __ ] uh Dylan hopefully you know
don't you know I'm hoping I'm hoping
that we get Kevin Durant he would be a
great [ __ ] Celtic whether he does
that or not I mean there's always some
place you know what this is the most
crucial time and I said I can remember
for the Los Angeles Lakers with Kobe
just [ __ ] retired okay their owner
[ __ ] died - now they got the son
cared that he is sorry that he had
nothing to do with the Lakers I was just
quoting uh what movie was that and then
your son
[ __ ] daddy is left these drivers
like to row maps yeah they have to make
something happen
they got to throw their [ __ ] money
around I don't know they don't have the
coach thing either this could be for the
first time you realize that the Lakers
have won more [ __ ] championships since
1970 than any other team in any other
major sport so I got to respect what
they've done more so than what anybody
else has done prior to that because
prior to that was the 23 skidoo years
where the [ __ ] was in [ __ ] basically
black and white you know segregated
leagues the Stanley Cup was the size of
a shot glass
you know the Celtics used to win there
would be like [ __ ] five white guys
against five white guys or maybe five
against four white guys and then Bill
Russell was out there you know I mean
it's just it's just a completely
different time you know I don't know
we'll see so anyways let me do a little
bit advertising here sorry my brains all
over the place and I just still can't
get over how [ __ ] people get mauled
2016 20 [ __ ] 16 I mean to get mauled
to death by a [ __ ] tiger in 2016 it's
like and I have takeaway I think the
probability of getting run over by a
stagecoach is is just as probable like
how many people gained oh and I gotta
look it up
death by stagecoach you know they're
gonna be spending some wow this show in
Oklahoma fell off the chuck wagon okay
you know it's going to be a guy to man
killed under stagecoach see if we get
see we get it did you mean man killed
under stagecoach one word I guess I did
unsettling events
stagecoach robberies police ID man
killed in Stoke crash fatal crash on
stage
drove 72 year-old man was killed Sunday
morning after a crash in West Lake when
township an authority said a vehicle
traveling northbound on stagecoach road
job I guess it doesn't happen and
whatever
let me get kicked by a horse something
stupid something that should be
happening during this time but why can't
you just admit that you were wrong
alright I was wrong
more probable to get mauled to death by
a tiger
alright let's uh let's just read some of
the advertising here Dollar Shave Club
everybody Dollar Shave Club comments a
special offer to new members who join
today you get a free month of the
executive razor when you buy a tube of
ducted calves easy visa this is the
first time they've ever done something
like this and once you tried
dollarshaveclub.com you'll be you'll
become a proud member like millions of
others just puff in your chest out as
you walk down the street i cheap razors
what are you doing with your life one
reason is because they deliver amazing
razors right to your door for a third of
the price of what the greedy rates at
corporations charge that means when you
join DSC you can afford to shave with a
fresh blade anytime you want which feels
fantastic you feel like you're running a
bank right you get a first-class shave
when you use the executive blade without
hurting your wallet another reason is
dr. Carver's shave butter can't believe
it's not carving using it with the
executive makes the blade glide gently
for the smoothest shave ever dr.
Carver's shave butter dr. caddy is it
your average shave cream it's a unique
conditioning formula with high quality
natural ingredients leaving your skin
feeling unbelievably smooth and soft and
right now new members who buy a tube of
the shave butter get the executive razor
for free they've never done this before
take advantage of it it's only available
by going to dollarshaveclub.com / /
that's dollarshaveclub.com / bur now
Jesus Christ tell me look at this week
alright trunk club chocolate truck club
was started to solve a simple problem
shopping for clothes in stores is
overwhelming and
it's not overwhelming it sucks who wants
to do that you know at least I don't I
don't want to [ __ ] do that so if I
don't want to do that then I assume
everybody else does it thank God for
trunk love because with trunk up you'll
discover great clothes that are perfect
for you oh if you look at this shirt
without ever having to go shopping we
combine top brands expert service and
unparalleled convenience to deliver a
highly personalized personalized
experience that helps you look your best
trunk club is not a subscription service
we send you clothes only when you ask
zero signup or monthly fees yeah you
can't ask for anything more than that
look at that you know that's in your
shirt whatever you want we send trunks
refrain from saying boxes alludes to
subscription service I didn't I have
said what the [ __ ] you wrote why would
you put that sentence in the copy you
know I'm going to read it don't talk
about price talk about quality hey don't
tell me what the [ __ ] to do I'm reading
one she was right what the [ __ ] you want
me to read you [ __ ] how did this go
from coffee to them wagging their finger
at me I'll talk about where the [ __ ] I
want to talk about you know if you want
to go to the [ __ ] mall this is a
great thing okay they got I can
paraphrase all of this they have us an
expert stylist in other words someone
who eventually will actually get paid a
decent amount of money to pick out these
clothes but right now they're new to the
business so take advantage of their
talent while they still work for trunk
club ok you tell them your basic styles
I like concert t-shirts and flip-flops
whatever your [ __ ] deal is and then
they'll get somebody to go out they pull
a bunch of [ __ ] they stick it in the
trunk they send it to you you keep what
you want you take everything else you
don't want you throw it back in the
[ __ ] trunk and you send it back to
them and that's it and they don't send
you any more [ __ ] until you ask them to
because it's not a prescription service
all right if you'd like to take
advantage of this go to [ __ ] whatever
the hell it is trunk club please don't
mention of competitors I don't even
understand this there's this is like
this is more a letter giving me [ __ ] for
what I've been doing alright I'm going
to say its trunk Club calm slash bar
that's what I would go with em VMT
watches you know it's been a few weeks
now since I cracked open the show
looking more in Jesus Christ why did I
keep doing this to me why do they keep
I'm a taste puppy probably sent this
copy out to every person with the
podcast and everybody goes you know it's
been a few weeks since I cracked open
these sharp-looking movement watch boxes
I did I saw that [ __ ] great they look
like expensive watches and you know but
I am a [ __ ] 48 year old man so I have
an expensive watch and I'm gonna
continue wearing that if I was in like
20s or my early 30s if I gone to a
divorce these are the [ __ ] watch for
you okay so you can still attract some
expensive tail all right without you
know you still have money to buy or
drink that's basically it
all right if you haven't had a chance to
experience how a movement watch fits
around your wrist this is the chance
movement watch should start at just $95
see when movement cut out the middleman
with the huge big Bank brand markups the
price of a stylish watch finally got
affordable imagine that exclamation
point a watch with the department store
quality for a fraction of the price okay
so if you want one of those things go to
nvm t m v mt watches dot-com / bar and
they'll give you 15% off your entire
purchase MV mt watches comm / / alright
Stan's calm everybody stamp a lamp is
calm this is the last one all right
stamps calm everybody tips to the post
office are never convenient so why not
get postage right from your desk with
stamps calm stamps.com even gives you
special postage discounts you can't get
at the post office including first-class
Priority Mail express international in
Lua you'll never pay full price for
postage again here's how stamps.com
works using your own computer and buying
foreign official US postage for any
letter or package then hanneke a male
companion mail to the mailman or drop it
in a mailbox it's that easy
no wonder over six hundred thousand
small businesses already use stamps calm
I use dance comm anytime I have my
posters when I'm whoring myself out
after my shows I send them out I'm a
[ __ ] if I can figure out how users
should soak in you right now sign up for
stamps comm using my last name BIR for
this special loss of four week trial
plus $110 bonus offer that includes a
post including postage in a digital
scale
don't wait get started with Spanish calm
today goes jeff's calm before you do
anything else click on the microphone
atop the homepage and type in birth be
you are Ardex pants comm enter ber
alrighty then and add damn but then add
an and I'll take care of that [ __ ]
mall to death by a tiger
you know [ __ ] you know attacked by a
bear in the wilderness as you're walking
around with [ __ ] twenty children that
aren't yours I mean that sounds like an
episode of Law & Order
boo-boo-boo-boo-boo like what the [ __ ]
were you doing out with with all those
kids I found them um alright my gym got
delayed by some [ __ ] you know not to
[ __ ] just some [ __ ] and I'm just
like now do it right like we can do it
this way or we can do it the right way I
might do it the right way so I have not
been working out and I've been eating
like [ __ ] because I'm just like bull the
second the gyms there I'm going to
[ __ ] go like a madman but uh Jim's
taking longer than I thought and you
know Oh Billy start to look like some
overcooked mashed potatoes and I'm not
liking it I'm not liking it one bit
alright let's let's do some reeds here
let's do some reeds oh you know what I
didn't talk about any other playoff
series did I I think of the other NHL
once the the filthy Flyers are down - OH
- the Washington Capitals and they are
they are the perennial favorites in the
Eastern Conference see real quick Tampa
Bay Lightning leads Detroit 2-1 Detroit
won the last one they [ __ ] read backs
up against the ropes big victory they're
Islanders over the Florida two games to
one Nashville is up two games to none of
a [ __ ] an I'm all this sucks bad
[ __ ] the Kings then the Ducks are
going to get knocked out no playoff
hockey throw [ __ ] freckles out here
Dallas is up two games to none I'm
completely in the dark with all of this
[ __ ] because I'm going to be in the
writers room I'm in the writers room for
the next 18 weeks total to write the the
second season and believe it or not I'm
actually finding that I love
in the writers room I thought it was
something that I was not going to enjoy
because of the freedom that I had as a
comedian but turns out I really like
writing scripts and I like writing
dialogue and all of that [ __ ] and we're
having a great time and I think you guys
hopefully are going to enjoy it so now
your next question should be built how
many episodes they give you 10 10
episodes for season 2 and when is it
going to be it when is it going to come
out probably this time next year its
animation that's how long it takes I
think they're saying May of next year is
when it comes out unfortunately but
that's how it works but it's going to be
worth the wait but I open now that we're
kind of going that once we do this one
we can immediately go into season 3 I
don't know how it [ __ ] works I guess
that wouldn't make sense they got to see
how many people watch season 2 I don't
know I think by the time we finished
season 5 I'll be 60 that's what I'm
guessing all right let's do some
questions here for the week come to
Prague come to Prague I'd like to go try
hey Billy wingnut just so you know we
started using your songs at circle time
circle time is every morning at 9:15
after yoga is it is songs in words and
learning English all the kids singing
our Czech kids please come to Prague the
[ __ ] is circle time sounds oddly filthy
circle time Prague Prague
linguistic circle homepage [ __ ] that I
know what that means I can't tell you
this so I've stuck with the French of 51
[ __ ] days and now it's starting to
just be in my head I still can't speak
it well if somebody's speaking it I pick
out a few words but like reading it I'm
crushing it reading I read I transcribed
this whole [ __ ] article about the
Pope saying that you know as much as the
Catholic Church has been against condoms
there are certain instances you know
that they don't think it's bad to use
them you know especially preventing the
spread of hiv/aids whatever you know and
they said something about you know
unprotected sex with male prostitutes I
think the best what it said I couldn't
tell us was that or men going to
prostitutes I couldn't quite get the
translation so I'm sticking with it and
because on duolingo too if you do a
hundred days in a row they give you a
couple of trinkets whatever the [ __ ]
that means so I'm I'm over the hump a
run downhill now and I don't I just
think I'm - I'm really doing it not only
did I want to learn how to do it but I
just think it's funny if someone is dumb
as me becomes completely fluent in
French and then that gives me the
opportunity to go to France or go to
Montreal and act like the dumb American
and then listen to what they're saying
about me and then just [ __ ] hit him
over the head with some [ __ ] I can't
say perfect French but like fluent
French just watch this [ __ ] in the
little [ __ ] pocket squares get all
[ __ ] in a bunch that's why I'm doing
it I'm doing it it's going to take I
know how long it's going to take me
judges I want to have that moment just
once in my life where I can just sit
there and have somebody trashing me in a
different language and they don't know
that I can hear everything
I understand everything that they're
saying just so I can look at them and
then [ __ ] come back and like a DVD
video basically saying like I know
exactly what you said all right I'm
sorry
most people want to learn so they can
communicate not me not me I want to do
it so I can have an argument on the
other side of the world what does that
say about me all right
cooking question dear Billy the butter
basting
ah that was a ghetto see there you go
there you go something original
I like that made fun of my cooking you
kept the alliteration going you called
me a [ __ ] in the end of it I give that
one four stars four stars alright
anyways I am a huge fan and I blah blah
blah blah yadda yadda yadda my question
is thank you for blowing through all
that my question is you used to talk
about cooking all of the time but now
you rarely do what gives did you stop
cooking if not what have you made lately
please make more cooking videos like the
pie crust one you made I need something
new to check off - thanks - go [ __ ]
yourself yeah I haven't been cooking I
when I when we write these episodes for
afters for family I'm so [ __ ]
relieved I can finally talk about this
[ __ ] it consumes my life I mean I
basically I go in at 10:30 every morning
there's usually some other [ __ ] I
have to do so I'm using there by 10:00
in the morning and then we [ __ ] write
all day till about 7:00 and by the end
of it I just come home I pour a scotch I
stare at the wall I fall asleep my dog
wakes me up at 7:00
I take her for a walk I come home I have
breakfast I try to bang out a podcast
and maybe do a little bit of French and
then I go right back to work so I don't
have time to [ __ ] do anything you
know I should do I should start using
blue apron you know I shall Marc Maron
he actually cooked a meal on it looks
[ __ ] delicious but I should really
start doing something like that because
I have been eating like a sort of in a
good way in sort of bad way I had the
best [ __ ] burger I've ever had
in Los Angeles and that is saying
something and if you'd like to know
where to go the next time you see me
when you're in Los Angeles you ask me I
will tell you what the places but I'm
not saying it on a podcast because I
hate when Anthony Bourdain does that and
this is cool [ __ ] spot and then he
makes it he makes it [ __ ] you know
every Tom Dick and Harry's got to go out
there and then it comes under new
management
think it's [ __ ] up so or even if I'm
out on the road so I'm out on the road
just yell it out during my show okay so
is that good for a spot here in LA
you know you bought a ticket I'll tell
you then you listen to this podcast for
free you don't get the information
oh is it delicious the fries were okay
the total was you know and the Mexican
[ __ ] coke and the Fanta orange with
the real sugar incredible credible
tasting that's that's where this country
is right now coca-cola is made better in
Mexico than it is in the United States
what does that say about us you know and
it's Donald Trump Hillary Clinton or
[ __ ] Bernie Sanders even approach
that at any point during this campaign
they might have Lord knows on that
watching all right so know where I last
left I was trying to learn how to make
no key and I failed miserably and my own
wife the woman who's supposed to love me
unconditionally sickness and health and
good times and in bad and when I made no
key it was a bad time and what did she
do did she stick by me
did she say it's okay and rub my head
nope you know what she said she leaned
over she goes hey and I was like what
she got right mayor and she goes you
should make pasta anymore
she said you shouldn't make pasta
anymore you know maybe she knows me well
enough to know that when somebody says
something like that to me that just
makes me go all right I'm gonna [ __ ]
master this [ __ ] you know I mean it's
not like you know something says you
shouldn't sing anymore you shouldn't
dance anymore maybe I understand that I
mean I [ __ ] there's just certain
things but I mean cooking it's just one
of those things are you you just do it
you can learn how to do it like all
these [ __ ] people on the Food Network
they don't have any they don't have any
Talent it's just they just you know they
have any friends and they just [ __ ]
you know they started off making cereal
and then they just kept progressing I'm
kidding I know it's an art form all
right [ __ ] relax okay put your apron
back on and go [ __ ] and make a souffle
all right so um yeah so I'm kind of
stuck on that but the next time I go to
New York I met somebody I met somebody
very special I met somebody in New York
chef at this Italian restaurant he told
me he'd like the real deal like right
off the books and anytime you come to
New York he goes I'll show you how to
make pasta from scratch bla bla bla bla
cuz I took a pasta making class and I'm
supposed to have been email a bunch of
[ __ ] to help you out and I never had any
follow-through and then I waited too
long to try it again and I finally I
kind of forgot some of the tricks so
that's where I met with the cooking
thing in and as far as making like the
cooking videos I did the pie crust thing
because there was nothing I just thought
was funny someone like me knows how to
do something like that but like I can't
cook better than most of the people out
there so it won't understand the point
of it maybe if I learn how to make no
key I'll teach you guys how to do it but
I'll have to do it for a long time
before I'll feel like confident enough
to make a video
maybe if I [ __ ] it up it'll be funny I
have no idea alright let's let's keep
reading here shall we
okay all right garden old Billy topsoil
one of my favorite things you used to
talk about was your garden and your
steps towards getting off the grid my
question is do you still have a garden
and are you still taking steps to get
off yourself off the grid now I mean I
have a lemon in a lime tree so I'll
never get scurvy no I just the level of
like commitment that that takes then you
have to have like a [ __ ] henhouse and
[ __ ] you know I don't have time to
become mr. Greenjeans and then what do I
have to have a henhouse guy I have to
have the chicken guy you know I mean
it's like as you accumulate [ __ ] then
you have to get to something guy right
you know you buy a [ __ ] house you
immediately you have a plumber you got
to have a [ __ ] electrician you know
you gotta have a basically a handyman
okay then what then you have a garden
then you got to have a [ __ ] landscape
or gardening guy because you're too busy
doing whatever you do for a [ __ ] cook
a living you get a pool you need the
pool guy you know you get a dog you got
the [ __ ] dog guy to vet guy all of
that shit's just more money flying out
of your [ __ ] wallet and um I am very
envious of people
that have their own gardens in that type
of [ __ ] but I you know I have my little
piece of [ __ ] la out here which is
not much we all live on topics I'm
literally looking out my window right
now and I see the roof of the person's
house next to me that's just basically
how it works you know I look out the
back I look out my back window and I see
the apartment buildings the back of the
apartment buildings from the street over
there's really not a place to plant some
turnips although I wish there was I
don't think I could really get away with
like having [ __ ] chickens and [ __ ]
some rooster crowing every morning
because the noise ordinance is noise is
not supposed to leave your property
although most people the second they
turn on this stereo they break that
[ __ ] thing but I would love to do it
I'd love to get solar panels and be off
the grid but she really can't be still
have to give them a little bit of money
actually I don't know how it works but
they have some so I know I works the
president makes four in a grand a year
so they go yes listen [ __ ] oh you want
the second term make this a law we said
make it a law right next we know it's a
lot because people live in the middle of
nowhere The Electric Company finds them
and then they like they sue them like
you have to give us money every month
which is uh I just don't understand how
that is legal that goes around so many
things that this country is allegedly
about if someone would force you I
understand taxes so I get do you want to
live here you got to kick in for the
potholes I get that but you have to buy
power from this [ __ ] pellet don't
[ __ ] off but that's not how it works
it's not our work so if you guys know
how to do if you know how to get off the
grid by all mean not cuz I want to be up
the grid now cuz I give a [ __ ] that I
give money to the power companies I just
you know when the [ __ ] hits the fan I
would like to be that beacon of light
that all the zombies run to right you
still got a flat screen alright
girlfriends wait oh jesus here we go
dear bill I'm a 21 year old guy my
girlfriend is 20 we've been taken
talking for about six months now and we
just recently decided to make it
official now here's the part where I
need your expert advice oh Jesus how
should I go about telling her I think
she
needs to lose weight she's not a fat ass
by no means but she could lose a few
pounds now like so now I sound like an
ass I know it sound like an [ __ ] I
think is what he's supposed to say yeah
I know he sound like an [ __ ] but I
care about her and want to see her be
more confident thanks for the help I
enjoyed this show in Long Beach
how'd he say she could lose it there
there is no way what I would do is I
would get yourself in great shape and
start getting her into hiking with you
and like you know but you can't make
somebody work out you can't make
somebody get in shape they either want
to do it or they don't and you know
that's like a major major major [ __ ]
you know you telling a woman she needs
to lose a few pounds is like that's the
female equivalent of them saying to you
like you know you dick could be a little
bigger it's devastating I wouldn't say
it to her but uh you know you also got
to think you know at 20 if they could
lose if they're already getting out of
shape at 20 years of age you know then
what then they have a couple of kids
they're going to be a [ __ ] house I
mean that's just something you get you
got to be honest about if someone
doesn't take care of themselves you know
and this works both ways to ladies like
if there was some guy and he's in his
20s and he's sitting there and he's
already getting Mantic it's not going to
get better and you got to sit there and
really just be like how much do I love
this person because I'm going to watch
them slowly eat themselves to death
because that's what you're doing and
unfortunately your chickens start coming
home to roost in your 40s whatever the
[ __ ] you did whenever you start to go
off the rails at 16 or 17 with drinking
drugging eating or whatever right around
when you get to your 40s is when the
first like like goddamn that happened to
him I thought that with some old man
[ __ ] you're like oh wait we're in our
40s because you'll still feel like
you're in your 20s so
I don't know I would go a positive route
I would just tell her how I would tell
her let me tell her how good she looks
at me just [ __ ] I don't there's no
way to do it that that is that there's
no that's a fortress and there's no door
in you know what I mean there's no door
in on that one you just have to just if
you're going to say it if you just
[ __ ] say it then you're really
risking like hurting her really bad you
know what I mean
anyone Jelena you know what a [ __ ] do
that you know I wonder if women ever
feel that way about guys like if there's
anything like there's like you know what
you just can't say that to a guy because
that will hurt them too much do they
ever think [ __ ] like that I think she'd
like that with women it's just certain
things you just you just don't [ __ ]
play like what is all I'm going to do is
hurt her in ruiner for the next person
when she [ __ ] eventually comes to her
senses and dumps me and then you'll be
that you know what this guy said to me
one time we were going into Whitby and I
ordered a double cheeseburger any
interrupt and he said no no no she was
single you don't being that guy no I
don't know I don't know what to tell you
I can't tell you that though I feel like
when you are you know aside from just
owning it to yourself to try to stay in
shape when you're in a relationship with
someone to just [ __ ] let yourself go
and just become a fat [ __ ] and you know
to just not have the consideration that
somebody is sort of obligated to have
sex with you to just try and remotely
keep yourself looking halfway decent
it's really a selfish [ __ ] thing you
know but we live in the age of a lot of
times the victim is is the is not is is
considered like the antagonize er you
know what I mean I would never do that
to me I would never just [ __ ] put on
a hundred [ __ ] pounds just come
waddling into the [ __ ] bedroom listen
you know roll over on top of her and she
would be complete
grossed out and every woman listening to
this probably just went that picture
that me a hundred pounds have your naked
sweating on my upper lip crawling in the
[ __ ] bed yeah exactly
isn't that disgusting well that's that's
a two-way street sweetheart you know we
don't want to see you come [ __ ]
waddling into the room you know your
hips taking out the [ __ ] door Jim you
know what I mean it's just it's not a
not fair to either person you know when
you really look at it nobody understands
that more than gay guys I would say that
gay guys have the most respect for the
fact that someone's going to hook up
with them you know to me I wonder if
they have pound-for-pound in the best
[ __ ] shape than anybody else
or is it because they're trying to
attract guys and they know guys are I
can't even say that shallow because they
always say that guys a shallot when it
comes to that we are but like you
[ __ ] hold up something shiny a
woman's like I want that you know that
just is bad right Christ I'm all over
the map all right on trial for a joke
all right bill did you hear about the
entertainer who might get prosecuted for
his poem that trashed a head of state
what country they're calling him a comic
but I think maybe Europe's version of a
comic not the traditional standup well
it depends on where you go in Europe
Europe is a you know it's not the
biggest continent but that's all it's a
long [ __ ] trip from Paris over to
Moscow I think Moscow is technically
still in Europe designo the west coast
of Russia is he stuck getting into the
Eastern Europe doing up you know I mean
they they still with vampires out there
you can only imagine how that would
affect the artists in upcoming I don't
know I'm talking about all right
and Angela Merkel gave the go-ahead to
the Turkish Prime Minister to make an
inquiry which basically means put on
trial all because of a stupid poem
thought I hate when people do that
thought hmm talk about that yeah there's
a bunch of countries that are just
getting their first taste of stand
comic comedy and they are going through
their Lenny Bruce years which is what
happens that happened Lenny Bruce he was
put on trial he was arrested for
obscenity and all of that type of stuff
this is what happened and once the
government realizes that it's just jokes
and that a stand-up comic doing an hour
on jokes is not going to cause a
revolution and that they can relax and
continue to [ __ ] over their own
countrymen and sleep well at night doing
it then they usually ease up on it and
people are allowed to you know do
stand-up comedy like what's funny now is
what's happening is there's this new you
know sort of I don't know what you would
call it Lenny Bruce time but it's just
more through people in the crowd though
but it's not the government anymore so
it's really no big deal it's just you
know people with agendas and websites
and [ __ ] like that you know clickbait
clickbait people right all right
boyfriend wants to have sex with other
girls I want to do the way to basically
support that person Angela Merkel can I
help pay for the lawyer kick in you know
all the comics around the world take
control 20 bucks at it and they could
tie it up in the Turkish court can that
happen I don't [ __ ] know oh you know
I'm going to look that up I'm glad you
brought that to my attention I know that
there was some somebody in Canada the
same thing happened and it's one of
those things where it's like you want to
talk about it but you also don't want to
feed that [ __ ] beast and give it all
types of notoriety
but then you're also going to let the
fellow comic going through that [ __ ]
there's got to be a way in a stealth way
so hopefully put that fire out you know
when I was in India the podcast I did
the guys over there they were going
through some [ __ ] because they had a
were they did a roast and everything was
fine everybody laughed and then they put
it up on YouTube and you know it was
like 40 million different religions
there and somebody complained and you
know they were in a definitely a what's
the word I should use they were in a
they were in a situation over there when
I you know which is hilarious been a
[ __ ] walk
down the street with them like oh yeah
my gonna get [ __ ] arrested because
I'm with you guys
you know it's [ __ ] up I only spent 24
hours in India and I already miss it I
really want to go back I have such a
good time in the 24 hours despite the
fact I had to get a piece of paper to
leave which was really [ __ ] creepy
but um I was weird that I didn't I
didn't know what I was thought I was
going to think when I went there but I
felt an odd connection when I went there
which is one of the coolest things when
you travel like when you go every place
you go to it's going to be great when
you actually go to a place like why is
this [ __ ] place feeling like like
spent like like a home like I relate to
these people more so than a lot of
countries I've been to I was over there
going like that guy reminds me a rich
boss maybe because I hung out with a
bunch of comics I have no idea anyways
boyfriend wants to have sex with other
girls hi Bill hi Bill my boyfriend and I
have been together for over two years
recently we had broken up for a little
less than a month but we started talking
again we broke up because although he
loves me and wants to be with me so a
Buick um he still wants to have sex with
other girls our sex life isn't a problem
because we [ __ ] on a daily basis most of
the twice a day as I'm sure you supposed
to right time she was lost right time
most of the time twice a day and he
always says on the best he will ever /
will have he also believes that there is
a very slim possibility that there might
be something better for him and then he
wants to experience other people before
possibly spending the rest of his life
with me he's 25 years old so he is
pretty scared about staying with one
person for the rest of his life
we were both not ready for marriage or
that type of relationship but I feel
that ending a two and a half year
relationship over his urges isn't the
right thing especially since he still
loves me and wants to be with me he's
pretty unhappy but he knows that being
with other people won't help because he
will feel the exact same way
as he does now he tells me that I am
amazing and beautiful and he wants to
have a perfect relationship so I don't
understand why he wants to leave that
for something that is most likely going
to be shittier
can't go through another breakup with
him because it was horrible while we
were broken up he did have sex with one
girl and talked to multiple girls but he
didn't feel any better and he was still
unhappy without me please help I don't
know what to do and maybe this can help
him as well thanks a bunch
well first of all I'm not a [ __ ]
relationship expert but first of all I
got to give him kudos for just being
honest saying that this is what I want
to do well I'll talk to you because he
didn't write in so I would just say that
unfortunately this is where he is at 25
and you're not so if he wants to [ __ ]
and go out and do whatever the [ __ ] he
wants to do you know let him and then I
think you should get on with your life
but I don't think it's healthy for you
to have him keep calling you during this
time when he's out there [ __ ] other
people but still [ __ ] with your
emotions so I think you let them go and
let them go do whatever the [ __ ] he
wants to do and but this you don't have
any contact with them that might be a
guy thing where you need some sort of
closure or some [ __ ] and gradually talk
and then talk less and less and less I
don't know I'm a [ __ ] psycho when it
comes to that [ __ ] so that's what I
would do I would say at this point what
he's doing is he's trying to do what's
right for him so you have to do what's
right for you he's putting himself first
and his wants first so you should do the
same thing and there's nothing wrong
with what he's doing he could have
[ __ ] lied and said that he didn't
have urges and then gone and [ __ ]
around and you know I don't no matter
what he was going to end up hurting it
but he did it he did it he did it the
right way he told you he broke up with
you and yeah he's got to go figure some
[ __ ] out but I don't think he needs to
be calling you up and we talking to you
after a month and getting your heart
going again and giving you hope and then
but I don't know what I want to do would
you love you but it
go [ __ ] yourself with you wishy-washy
[ __ ] alright you know you're beautiful
you're young you got your whole life
ahead of you you know [ __ ] them just
[ __ ] I don't know once you have a
little you time over the next two to
three months see where you're at make a
little list figure out what you want out
of life you know who knows who knows
maybe he'll come back to you be like you
know what it sucked and you want to take
them back maybe you won't but I think
you need to focus on yourself and not
him that's that's what I would do
because you didn't pull the trigger he
did so there's no guilt on your end but
it's a shitty thing to do to do that to
somebody and then come back like a month
later and drag you through that hell all
over again but then not get back with
you and make some sort of a commitment
to just go back and be like oh you hope
that one person but as soon as you you
know cuz then you're gonna be like yeah
so what does that mean does that mean he
loves me and you guys took a plane that
mental tennis [ __ ] all that [ __ ] all
that alright they're wishy-washy
we'll see you just tell them what you
need you need yeah hundred percent
commitment that's it you're either in it
or you're out of it
I respect you the fact that you're on it
but you know I know I don't need you
[ __ ] hemming and hawing every [ __ ]
four weeks dragging me back down to that
emotional pit I'm done get all if you
like that's what I would do you know I
this [ __ ] jackass and then the second
you're getting on with your life you
won't want to lose you then he'll come
back and just so we won't lose one of
those [ __ ] guys that's what I'm
thinking yeah I would get on with your
life that's what I would do I hope
that's good advice oh I had no idea all
right that's the podcast for this week
thank you guys for listening and thank
you to everybody from the bottom of my
hat who watched the first season of
efforts for family we're really going to
try to outdo what we did in the first
season and try to make them as funny as
possible alright that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves and I'll check it out yes on
Thursdays to you